[Music]
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
here we go it is
people are ready for Splatoon we are
here we are back it is going down we're
going to set up shop and get the matches
top and we're about to see what is going
on let's get to it Splatoon three in the
building
closely deciding teams one of the most
highly anticipated Nintendo switch
releases let's go we about to get it
probably
let's get it
action
figure guys
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
okay
people getting ready
getting ready for Splatoon
foreign
[Music]
all right
[Music]
uh
doing today
everybody's ready the teams are ready
Are the team's ready for this platoon
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you move faster it depends on the
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah
baby baby
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
again
not not just this one I got you I got
you brother thank you no doubt no doubt
we'll get more action
s
is
over here
oh yeah I'm staying here
[Applause]
good guys have done it salute to the
good guys good job I love it
all right
still it's a low wait this is you
you might be banned from freshly playing
the lady of the level
look at everybody getting it in y'all
this is so cool yo Nintendo will be
showing out for the Arby there's one
thing about them
sensitivity
good
oh yeah
that's a good question this is the meter
what's the meter about okay
oh that's the shark thing oh that's cool
ability oh that's awesome that's awesome
foreign
with the raiding champion
I like it
foreign
there's power
all right
getting those nice success
oh my God it's crazy
a minute
I was looking for my see if I was all
ready to go ready to go
get out of here that's right
nice nice there you go
okay okay
[Music]
your tooth is very close match I picked
up knowledge it's a dangerous it is
really good how did you like it how did
you like it it's fun yeah it's fun so
you're a veterans with two employer no
my kids actually play it okay
um but I figured I'd you know at least
try it out we'll probably we'll probably
get it of course yeah I know the kids
really like it it's a kind of I mean I
spent a lot of time playing Call of Duty
and stuff but I mean yeah that's awesome
you did fantastic at that first match I
loved it yeah thank you
in the building showing out and showing
off we are going to get up out of here
but it has been absolutely a blast to
see Nintendo back at ax this is really
really cool to see thank you
no doubt for two three
they are doing anything salute taxis tax
West Nintendo is back Splatoon
later our little podcast once again.net
thank you
[Music]